california can expect another day of  severe fire danger  more strong winds are unlikely to whip  up fast moving wildfires south of los  angeles  they've already forced more than 90  thousand people to leave their homes  two firefighters are hospitalized with a  second and third degree burns  firefighters face another difficult day  ahead as those  high winds red flag warnings are  expected to be in effect  until this evening and sherry this was  something that you showed us live  pictures of this morning  you know they had 90 to 100 mile per  hour winds through areas of southern  california yesterday wow  some of the highest winds they've had so  far for the season it's been terrible  there